hallo mein name ist luca und wer also
mit spastischen youtuber drop machen den
jeder derzeit bringt kommt nicht wieder
vor ihr seht ihr schon im titel
eingeblendet und zwar unangenehme fragen
warum freue ich mich darüber so ihr
konntet ihr unter mein neuestes
instagram bild da konntet ihr mir
unangenehme fragen stellen da kamen
unglaublich viele kommentare an nicht
glaube irgendwie über 12.000 habe
anstatt also dass jeder youtuber mache
und die einfach beantwortet habe ich mir
gedacht ich ziehe die magische
miesmuschel app mit dazu fokus jedoch
immer die scheiße hier kommen kameras
sagt dass das ist die magische
miesmuschel app und die wahl entweder ja
oder nein wenn paar sekunden später
[Musik]
fällt deine schnauze ständer während der
schule die magische miesmuschel sagt was
für ein unfug muss ich nicht beantworten
diese frage hast du schon mal jemanden
geschlagen
jetzt hat die magische miesmuschel für
mich geantwortet quasi aber dass ich
nehme das mal so als antwort der
magischen miesmuschel dass sich die
frage beantworten soll also ich denke er
meinen jetzt nicht dieses normale dass
man jemanden einem kumpel einfach mit
backpfeife gibt oder meine kumpel
wegschubsen spaß sondern schon so dass
richtig geschlagen ich muss sagen ich
bin eigentlich sehr friedlicher mensch
also ich versuche solche gefechte
eigentlich immer mit worten zu lösen
einmal hat es nicht ganz geklappt das
war vor zweieinhalb jahren glaube ich
dass ich eine kleine schlägerei mit ein
paar kollegen die wurden halt einfach
provoziert und die haben dann angefangen
mit der handgreiflichkeiten sage ich mal
und die haben aber dann trotzdem von uns
auf maul bekommen und die haben uns dann
angezeigt aber wir haben das alles der
polizei erklärt und deswegen sind wir
nicht schuldig gesprochen worden sondern
das verfahren und einfach aufgelöst aber
naja wenn ich so ein derzeitiges ich
freestyle youtuber wäre würde ich
darüber auch ein neues video machen das
irgendwie nennen so ich hab mich geboxt
eine anzeige bekommen aber ich lass das
mal außen vor hast du schon mal in der
stadt laut gedacht zb die es geil und
sie hat es gehört schon unangebracht
wenn ich gerne hast du gesagt aber die
magische miesmuschel sagt nein wie
würdest du reagieren wenn max dir sagt
dass er auf dich steht aber nicht lieber
nichts also auch nicht beantworten hat
ein
dich schon mal begreift er nicht auch
nicht beantworten alter freunde hier ist
echt nichts eingestellt oder so nett
dass sie sind die einstellungen dann
kann man auch einstellen was kommt aber
ich habe wirklich die ganze zeit positiv
neutral und negativ also glaubt mir
einfach ich habe mir extra frage aus so
die ich alle beantworten würde wie viel
euro würdest du eine
geschlechtsumwandlung machen lassen
das war eigentlich so eine frage der ich
ausweichen wollte eine
geschlechtsumwandlung also eigentlich
muss ich sagen ich bin vollkommen
zufrieden mit meinem geschlecht also ich
meine ich weiß nicht wie es ist weiblich
zu sein oder so aber ich kann mich jetzt
nicht beschweren die sache ist halt
immer mit diesem geldbeträgen es ist mir
eigentlich scheißegal wie viel geld man
mir geben würde weil ich würde es nicht
machen also ich bin vollkommen zufrieden
mit meinem jetzigen körper und 400
millionen euro
das kann kein mensch auftreiben hast du
schon mal mit einer frau geschlafen die
älter ist als du zum beispiel 36 jahre
muss ich auch beantworten ich meine
fragt mich ob ich schon mal mit einer
älteren frau geschlafen habe und gibt
dann als beispiel eine 36-jährige an
älter als ich kann auch schon 20 seien
ja ich habe schon mal mit einer älteren
frau geschlafen aber sie war nicht 36
sondern ich glaube einfach nur ein paar
monate älter
ich hoffe das genügte jetzt als antwort
findest du eine youtube in extrem heiß
alter der hat mir am anfang diese
beschissenen fragen einfach nur negativ
betitelt und jetzt muss ich diese ganzen
fragen beantworten hier ich muss sagen
es gibt bei youtube drin wo ich auf
jeden fall sagen würde die sind heißt
das sind aber keine deutschen allerdings
finde ich da muss so beides stimmen also
es gibt youtuber denn diese ultra nett
und es gibt youtube sind ultra heiß aber
es gibt so nicht das mittel gegen
deswegen könnte ich mir zum beispiel
nicht vorstellen derzeit mit irgendeiner
bekannten youtube zusammen zu sein wie
auch fast schon besoffen muss ich nicht
beantworten
jetzt körperteil findest du an die am
hässlichsten natürlich nicht irgendwie
rettet die mich und dann jetzt gleich
meist mir wieder voll ins kalte wasser
bestimmt hattest du schon einen 38
so was muss ich jetzt beantworten also
erstmal freunde die sachen die ich hier
beantwortet sind unangenehme fragen dh
es müssen nicht alles irgendwelche
sexuellen fragen sein sondern es kann
auch was sein wie also wie soll man das
definieren unangenehme fragen sind für
mich einfach fragen wo ich sagen würde
okay würde ich jetzt im normalen fragen
wir nicht dran nehmen weil ich irgendwie
keine lust habe die zu beantworten
und jetzt beantworte ich mal die frage
hier ist eigentlich recht easy
nein ich hatte noch keinen dreier also
ich weiß nicht wie das ist es ist halt
einfach geschlechtsverkehr mit zwei
anderen personen und nein hatte ich noch
nicht das ist meine antwort hast du
peinliche unterhosen absolut warum sie
da ja man alter das hat mich so mega
abwehr erkennt hier der kamera immer nur
das gesicht hierhin und jetzt warten
jetzt fokussiert jetzt fokussiert der
mein gesicht dieses kissen aus
aber die frage war einbezogen ob meine
unterhosen also eigentlich rockig nur
solche unterhose irgendwie calvin klein
oder puma oder so ganz normale weil die
einfach am bequemsten sind peinlich
unterricht habe ich gar nicht also ich
habe jetzt nicht so was wo ich sagen
würde
da steht doch tochter doch moment das
ist jetzt zwar nicht wirklich meine
unterwäsche die ich euch zeige
allerdings habe ich bei dem video days
einmal das hier geschenkt bekommen und
dann unter anderem auch noch die
zeichnung ist es am besten das hier also
findest du mein tier deiner fans
herzlich krieg nicht danach aus zwar
einerseits die antwort den magischen
miesmuschel auch ob ich die frage nicht
beantworten sollen und die tatsächliche
antwort der frage wie findest du katja
geil auf jeden fall das war nicht die
beantwortung der frage ich weiß nicht
wie ich es konkret ausdrücken soll aber
ich finde dass ich glaube katja krasser
wisse dingsbums ist ja gemeint ich würde
sagen dass sie für mich einer der
hässlichsten menschen der welt ist und
ich glaube darüber schreibe ich jetzt
gerade nicht ich hasse menschen die so
viel an ihrem körper verändern dass es
nicht mal mehr schön aussieht sondern
einfach nur noch ekelhaft ich meine es
gibt ja einige leute und auch einige
leute auf youtube was an ihrem körper
getan haben ich glaube ja beispielsweise
parole hat auch was dran gemacht aber
das finde ich noch in wissen vor mehr
oder weniger natürlich auch wenn man das
so nennen kann aber dass bei katja ist
einfach nur noch komplett ekelhaft und
vollkommen an der normalität vorbei und
ich war also ich will über einen
überhaupt nicht da in sein leben
sprechen oder so bitte trifft die
entscheidungen
ich komme gar nicht richtig auf punkt
trifft die entscheidungen die euch
glücklich machen aber wenn ich gefragt
werde ob ich seine person geil finde
antwortet definitiven nein weil ich
feiere sowas überhaupt nicht und ich
find's einfach nur hässlich und dafür
brauchen wir jetzt keine irgendwie ans
kreuz nageln oder so weil das ist
einfach meine meinung und nach der wurde
gefragt wenn du schwul wäre wem würdest
du zuerst sagen
würdest du dann weinen wenn ich schwul
wäre hätte ich es erst schon längst
gesagt ich hätte es natürlich als
allererstes meiner familie gesagt und
dann halt hier auf youtube nicht werden
mensch denkt glaube ich damit komplett
offen leben würde ich weiß ich wenn ich
schwul wäre ich schon längst gesagt und
ich hätte da auch überhaupt nicht
geheult oder irgendwas meist komplett
normal ist ist ja schon mal was
peinliches beim pokémon bau spielen
passiert nicht danach aus okay gut ich
wollte die frage nicht beantworten das
war ein bisschen leben gewesen hat dich
bei deinem video einen tag in meinem
urlaub beim duschen gefilmt nicht er
gute soll die frage nicht beantworten da
jetzt erstmal ganz kurzes war meine
mutter also alles geholt glaubst du an
liebe auf den ersten blick wann immer du
dich kann ich auch ganz schnell
beantworten nein glaube ich nicht weil
zuliebe gehört nicht nur die äußerliche
seite daran glaube ich auf den ersten
blick man kann sich auf jeden fall auf
den ersten blick in das äußere einer
person verlieben aber zu liebe gott auch
das innere und das kann man ja nicht
beim ersten blick herausfinden wie eine
person von den emotionen und gefühlen
und vom inneren werten her ist hast du
schon mal als du dich mit einem mädchen
getroffen hast laut gefurzt oder gerückt
dafür die magische miesmuschel auf jeden
fall hört ein jahr habe ich also ich bin
da ganz ehrlich also wenn ich mit leuten
unterwegs bin und teilweise auch mit
freundinnen man kurz halt ab und zu das
ist komplett menschlich bist du schon
mal ohne schlüssel aus der wohnung oder
dem haus bin ich eigentlich doch aber
soll ich ja nicht beantworten warum
folgst du keinen fan pages mehr
[Musik]
theoretisch folge ich euch schon die
sache ist dass mein instagram profil
einerseits man öffentliches instagram wo
vieles und andererseits noch mein
privates instagram profil das heißt die
folge da hauptsächlich freunden und
kollegen von mir und ich habe die
benachrichtigungen bei instagram so
hingehen tan gemacht dass ich nur
benachrichtigungen von leuten bekommen
die dann in folge und ich bin mal eine
zeitlang richtigen wie zehn bis zwanzig
fanpages von euch gefolgt allerdings
habe ich da immer extrem viele
benachrichtigungen bekommen ein handy
war die ganze dann vibrieren weil ihr
natürlich sehr aktiv sind und dann
wiederum bilder von anderen
pages anderen accounts live und das
finde ich ultra cool dass die gegenseite
ist das support aber ich will einfach
nicht dass mein handy die ganze zeit
vibriert also wenn ich die
benachrichtigungen für bestimmte seiten
bzw bestimmte instagram profile
ausmachen könnte würde ich enorm viele
leuten folgen ich meine ich könnte jetzt
allein zum 50 fans von euch aufziehen
die alle vierstellig fünfstellige lei
xun das ist unfassbar ich weiß nicht ich
glaube ich muss mir nicht dafür
rechtfertigen aber ich finde eure arbeit
ultra cool und ich möchte nicht dass
irgendeine fanpage aufhört weil ich euch
alle marken gehören das war's vom video
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat last auf jeden fall
leichter und schreibt war und in die
kommentare apfelkuchen
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran sein
[Musik]